on voit bien la position de notre un
plan
de regarder vers le bas
très bien belle baisse de pression le
glaucome est l'une des plus graves
maladies de l'oeil causée par la
mauvaise circulation du liquide qui
provoque une forte pression sur le nerf
optique
c'est un processus lent qui touche 2 %
des plus de 40 1 10 % des gens très âgés
et qui peut provoquer une cécité totale
jean pierre blais 1 souffre depuis une
quarantaine d'années mère lorsqu'elle
est décédée est aveugle diogo comme
ma soeur qui est plus âgée que moi est
presque aveugle aussi aujourd'hui ses
deux yeux sont touchés surtout le gauche
imaginez jeu pas comme un délit j'ai pas
capable de rien écouté le télé où il ya
de ça on n'a pas de centre faut se
tourner la taille pour avoir quelqu'un
le glaucome est incurable mais
aujourd'hui on peut parfois freiner ou
même stopper complètement sa progression
récemment monsieur blé accepté de
participer à une première québécoise au
chum à montréal
l'installation de ce minuscule un plein
de 8 mm de longueur dans son oeil droit
en gros le but c'est de baisser la
pression dans l'oeil et avec cet implant
là ont créé une bulle de filtration sous
la conjonctive qui la partie de pau par
dessus la partie blanche de l'oeil est
sacrée cette bulle qui permet aux le
drainage de liquide et baisser la
pression née plein si petit que
l'ouverture du conduit qui vous
appellent ou diamètre d'un c'est
l'humain il faut des doigts de fée pour
l'insérer au bon endroit dans la bonne
position puis recoudre la conjonctive on
place un plan de sorte qu'ils soient
dans une zone où est ce que va pas voir
une bonne filtration de liquides ce qui
en moins de chances de cicatriser et on
doit s'assurer qu'il n'est pas bloquée
parce que comme il est tout petit il ya
plus de risque de bloquer la chirurgie a
duré à peine une année monsieur blais a
récupéré rapidement une semaine plus
tard il était très confiant la
technologie
est fait n'est pas incroyable puis
je suis bien heureux d'en profiter dans
le moment bien sûr faudra voir à l'usagé
si cette technologie tient ses promesses
là on va savoir dans les prochaines
années avec l'évolution de la
technologie avec l'évolution de la
technique chirurgicale à quel point on
est capable d'utiliser ces implants ont
elles ont toutes un long terme et
prévenir le gros con de continuer de
progresser ici norma grondin reste du
canada montréal